If you're watching this video, you're
probably very familiar with that feeling
of being put on the spot and having your
entire body start to rebel. I know for
me, like my heart would start pounding,
maybe your hands get sweaty or your ears
start burning. Like it's a really
uncomfortable feeling. This voice of
doubt would start creeping in saying,
"Oh no, this is this is a problem.
You're in trouble." And it's the reason
why most people avoid public speaking at
all costs. But it's actually the reason
to get better at the skill fast. Because
when you get better at it, what you're
doing is you're improving that
experience. You're minimizing that voice
of doubt. And you're essentially trying
to make those symptoms quieter and
quieter so that you can access a state
of flow and confidence. And when I say
confidence, I don't mean like
confidence. I mean like you'd feel more
relaxed. You'd feel at ease. You'd be
more grounded. And that's the same way
in speaking. When you start practicing
your public speaking and you start to
learn some of those essential skills
like pausing, staying in character,
starting with a story, you're able to
navigate scenarios more skillfully. And
as a result, you start to feel more
relaxed about your chances. You develop
this feeling of I got this. And we call
that trust. It's a trust in yourself and
in your abilities. And it replaces that
nagging voice of doubt and anxiety. And
the beautiful thing about the trust is
that it carries with you everywhere you
go. So you can bring it into your
meeting, your pitch, your presentation,
your social interactions. It's a
reliable sense of trust and confidence
that you have with you everywhere you
go.
And I remember back in 2016, in a span
of 6 months, I interviewed for a new
job, got that job, negotiated a 1.5x
salary, and then within that same 6
month span, I got a promotion and raised
my salary so that it was twice as much
as when I started. And I remember
feeling incredible and incredulous. I
kind of couldn't believe that all that
could happen because it was largely in
part of my communication skills. It
wasn't even that that I was that good at
the job. It's because I had these
important conversations that were kind
of uncomfortable, but that I practiced
and took a lot of confidence to have.
And that's why public speaking can
change your career so much is because at
the root of it, it comes down to
conversations and your confidence in
being able to navigate them. So, for
example, for job interviews, you're able
to think on your feet much faster.
You're able to answer questions
strategically, knowing that there's
really only one point to communicate for
every answer, and that storytelling
brings that message to life. Or maybe
you're negotiating a raise or trying to
increase your salary. Well, with a
little bit of practice, not only are you
able to have the courage to even have
the conversation, but if, for example,
your boss or your manager says, "You
know what? At this time, I'm sorry, we
just can't do it." Instead of saying,
"Oh, okay. Well, you know, thanks for
trying. You might ask a question like,
well, what if we created a road map?
What would it take for me to get that
promotion in 6 months or in 1 year's
time, you're much more willing to have
that uncomfortable conversation? The
people who get promoted have one common
ingredient. They ask for it. And they
ask for it not just point blank. They
take the opportunities at work to speak,
to lead, to inspire. and then they have
a track record that says, "Hey, I think
I'm up for that promotion." That's what
work has in common. I think no matter
what your job is, it's very likely that
speaking is going to be central to your
career the higher up that you rise in
the ranks. And I think that's because
communication ultimately comes down to
influence. The skill of influence is the
ability to effectively communicate your
message and get buyin from other people.
Buy in that you're worth the salary that
you're asking for. Buy in that you're
the right person for the promotion or
that you're the right person for the
job. If you start practicing public
speaking, you build the confidence and
the skills to have the important
conversations at work so that you can
accelerate your career. On the subject
of work, there are lots of mistakes that
people make in their presentations which
hold back their career. That's why we
created the ultimate public speaking
handbook. It's a free 5-day email course
on how to fix the five biggest mistakes
when it comes to presentation. So, if
you're interested, check that out and
let's get back to the video. So, the
final reason why I think public speaking
can change your life has everything to
do with outside of work. It's your
social life. And for me, I used to dread
social interactions. Unless it was just
like my close friends, I used to really
feel anxious when I would be in group
conversations. I wouldn't know how to
navigate them. I'd feel this sense of
I'm not interesting. I don't have
something worthwhile to say. People can
tell that I'm awkward. And it was just a
terrible experience from start to
finish. And I didn't know how to change
that until I started learning public
speaking. And it helped a little bit.
Eventually, I was able to maintain eye
contact with people. I remembered that
open body language is more impactful
than closed body language. And I had all
the outward sensations of a good
speaker. But inside I still felt kind of
like a fraud. And that's when I met
Tristan. And Tristan, my co-founder, had
this magical ability where he seemed to
be so at ease with anybody he talked to.
And it felt like any conversation he
could handle. He could talk about
anything with anyone. And he'd never run
out of things to say. And I asked him,
"How do you do that?" And what he told
me, I really took to heart. And he said,
"Look, it's not that I'm the same with
everyone that I'm talking to, but it's
that the delta between who I am with my
wife and who I am with my clients and
who I am with my friends and who I am
with strangers, that delta is really
small. Meaning, I'm comfortable cracking
jokes with people. I'm okay with being
myself. I feel like people can be my
friend if I want them to be." It's this
feeling of trust in people. And I really
started to practice that. And one of the
ways that I started to practice that, I
know it sounds super silly, but I
started to keep my mouth open instead of
closed. Tristan noticed that at dinners,
my mouth would be closed when we'd be
with clients, but open when it would be
just me and him. And it was like this
subconscious way that I was withdrawing
and constraining my voice when I felt
uncomfortable. And as a result, it gave
me kind of that little reminder of, hey,
don't withdraw. Say the funny thing or
introduce the idea. And then when I
learned how to never run out of things
to say, I would always have association
techniques like, "Oh, you talked about
what you were reading. Well, reading
makes me think of books and I'm reading
a book on habits. I want to talk about
habits." And I started to contribute to
conversations in ways that I never had
the comfort and ease before. And that
transformed my social life.
I became deeply okay with all of the
situations. And I felt like, oh, I like
myself. And I could feel like any
conversation that I was having was a
good one. And that truly transformed my
life because it got rid of all of the
dread and self-judgment and
self-criticism, all that negative talk
that I had of I don't like myself. It
finally started to dissipate and I
became much more comfortable being who I
am today. So to recap, public speaking
is the skill that can change your life
and there's three reasons. Number one,
it helps you build confidence in
yourself and eliminate that voice of
doubt. Number two, it's going to take
your professional success to the next
level. And number three, it's going to
make all of your social interactions
much more easy and enjoyable. And when
you combine all those and stir it in the
pot, it just creates a life that tastes
sweeter and that brings more
opportunities your way. So, if you like
this video, the one I'd recommend you
watch next is the fastest way to improve
your speaking skills. That's a no BS
video on what I've seen work to
accelerate people's progress in this
skill. Otherwise, I really appreciate
you watching. We're really excited to
take this channel to the next level and
start putting out more videos. So, if
you liked it, please subscribe. It gives
me a little warm feeling in the heart
and I'd really appreciate it. And again,
thanks for watching. I'll see you in the
next video.